se perdió el contacto con el que reinan
gala 402 el miércoles ahora se juega una
carrera contrarreloj para encontrar el
submarino indonesio que según los
oficiales que participan en la búsqueda
ya se habría quedado sin oxígeno a las 3
de la mañana del sábado en indonesia
nos piden que no sucumbamos al pánico
estoy confundida porque no debería
aterrorizar mi
busque en internet y encontré que el que
reinan gala había perdido la
comunicación sólo queremos la
información más precisa posible
helicópteros y embarcaciones salieron de
bali de la base naval dejaba este
viernes en dirección al área donde se
perdió el contacto con el submarino se
han enviado seis zonas de equipamiento
para ayudar con la misión
esperamos que nuestra familia los
soldados del cae reinan gala 402 estén
sanos y salvos y los podamos encontrar
pronto
se ha detectado un objeto con una alta
atracción magnética a una profundidad de
entre 50 y 100 metros mientras que
previamente la búsqueda aérea ha visto
una fuga de combustible cerca de la
última ubicación del submarino
la flota de malasia y singapur están en
camino para ayudar en la búsqueda otros
países como francia rusia turquía y eeuu
también pusieron sus efectivos a
disposición de indonesia
a petición del gobierno de indonesia
vamos a enviar con iron transportadores
el patrullero marítimo navy 8 poseidón
para asistir en la búsqueda del
submarino
la nave podría resistir a una
profundidad de 500 metros pero más allá
no aguantaría la presión del agua